The Joe Rogan experience. I did.
I remember when you lost your job at Nickelodeon,
we were in the parking lot or John jocks. And this is like, what year was that?
Um, I hadn't been, uh, you know what? It had been 98, 98 because I had a house.
I just bought a townhome in Belinda.
Yeah. And we were talking and you're like, I don't know what to do. Yeah.
Like I'm thinking, you know, but just like just, you know, working on my art.
I remember that conversation, man. And then I remember like years later,
you're balling out of control and your arts and galleries.
And I had a friend and I went over his house and he had one of your paintings
above his kitchen tables. Like, Holy, that's Todd, White's painting. He's like,
you know that guy, I go, I do jujitsu with him. I'm like, wow. He goes, yeah,
he's really talented. He's really good.
It was like one of those cocktail party paintings.
I remember thinking this is nuts, man. I'm at someone else's house.
And Todd White's painting is above his kitchen tables while I love that.
I was telling you the other day, just earlier today,
rather that I'm sure the restaurant out here, I go in,
had no idea. I just go in me and my wife round date night,
we walk in and I'm like, this is Todd White's paintings are everywhere. Yeah.
Thank you. It's it's what your style is so distinctive, you know,
I could see you're like either someone's ripping you off or it's you.
So like when I walked in there, I'm like I'm 99% sure.
This a Todd white or some Todd white.
It's. Uh, so, you know, I had, I had 13 years in animation.
I came out of high school. I got a job at Warner brothers as a carer,
as a production assistant on the first season of tiny Toons. But,
but what I did is I just, I looked at every super talented artist,
every draftsman and I would ask questions and, uh, I was drawing every day.
I had no social life and, uh, they would give me such great advice.
So I looked at it that's my college because I didn't go to school.
My mom was a painter. So I grew up in a painting household. Her mom was as well.
And uh, I just looked at it as I'm going to educate myself through, you know,
the hard work and the grind. And before I knew it,
I was just around some of the most talented artists in the industry.
And they were showing me techniques and, and way to,
to way to put life into character in a way to give a drawing life,
which is the hardest thing. By the way, I look at a lot of paintings in it.
They may be technically great, but there's no life they're dead looking.
The eyes are dead, it's a dead looking painting.
And so I learned through super talented artists to
teach me how to put that kind of personality and life into the
drawing, and then translate that into the painting. And, uh,
I was always obsessed with the rat pack and Sinatra and Dean Martin and Sammy
Davis Jr. And I just, I would,
I had few HS tapes of them at the summit and everything.
And I used to watch them all the time and try to look like they were having so
much fun.
Men were men and women were Dames and they had the drinks and the cigarettes and
they were blowing smoke in each other's face.
And they weren't worried about masks. It was just amazing time. And, and, uh,
women were Dames. I loved it. You know, games is such a great word. And so, uh,
so I just kind of, I wanted to capture that in painting and I wanted to,
I want to kind of bring some of that timelessness back and, uh, and you know,
I would, uh, I was really good with marker work, uh, marker color comps, uh,
in animation because I quickly after that I became a character designer.
And so I spent the next, you know, 10 years in animation,
designing characters for shows. And I ended on SpongeBob and that was like, uh,
Steve Hillenburg a lot of my friends from a previous show said, Hey,
we're going over Nickelodeon. They got this new show they're working on,
it's a pilot SpongeBob. And they need a character guy. And,
and I met with Steven and he said, uh, he gave me Marine biology books.
He's like here, make these characters. And uh, I went home Marine biology book.
He was a Marine biologist. He went to Cal arts. He wasn't the best draftsman,
but he had good ideas. And, uh, and he was really cool dude, and a surfer.
And so.
Why Marine biology was he just cause it was all.
About underwater life. I don't know if you've ever seen the show.
Well, I've seen a few times in my kids. I never paid attention.
I just know it was under water.
Yeah. It's all bubble. Guppies is underwater.
I don't know what that is. I actually can't stand watching it. I don't,
the kids have so many shows going on and they're also horrible to watch.
So I don't stare at any.
Yeah. Bubble guppies was, uh, my daughter's favorite show for like two years.
Um, your style, like go to his website and pull up some of the,
or pull some of the images of it. Your,
are they all like this? Like your you're.
Do you do other kinds of styles or is it most of your work?
Like cocktail party?
I, I view my work as a it's all personality and relatable. So in my mind,
uh, I'm gonna, I'm not painting art for your furniture or your living room.
I'm not painting something you want to put in your living room.
I'm painting something that you want, that you identify with. And, uh,
I think a lot of people.
What do you mean by that? Like if it's not for the living room, like,
whereas if you identify.
Yeah. It's it. Wherever you identify, where you identify, see yourself in it,
you see yourself, you see your boys weekend at Vegas.
At time we had the greatest time ever.
The women had girls' night out and they see their new stuff on Instagram at all.
No interest to have my new.
Stuff cartoonish. Oh, okay.
I hate that word cartoonish.
Yeah, really? What's a good word. Cat character, character. But no,
one's going to know what.
I know. I know people, there you go. There's some new stuff right there.
That's like the foxes and um, you know,
so I always want to represent someone's life.
I want them to see their life and I don't want them to see their personality and
their kids.
Go back to that picture again. The jokes and foxes,
the blonde, the like from the left-hand side, the third one, she looks like a.
Oh, good, good group of fours.
Yeah. Integrates the more that's what you're going to have. Cam, see,
everyone has their own editor. Everyone has their own attitude.
Everyone has their own personality. Like out of those three,
you know why she gets everything she wants.
She far left the one in the white that's my kind of.
Girl smiling thought seems like she's happy. She saw that. Wow.
That one you got to work for that one. That's holding that wine glass too low.
She's just too much.
What do we like? We like to throw the hunt, not the thrill of the kill.
I like nice people. I get my thrills and other places.
I don't want them in relationships. I look for conflict and relationships.
I just look for nice people, man. I liked the one you got lucky I did too.
I liked the one in the white. That's my kind of girl, but that one,
the one with the low wine glass, I'd tell my friends, bro, please,
please don't burn the house. Sure. Shat.
So those three I've no problem with any of those girls are fine.
Those are fun things. The one that James get the cursor over,
she's going to be the most problems. She's going to overdose at your house.
She's going to.
What are we doing? We're having conversations about stupid art, right? Like, so,
you know, art should be a conversation piece.
The one on the far, right. She's going to your friends, my friends.
You're going to love me.
She's going to text your friend move and then she's going to all your friends.
Yeah. So it should be a conversation piece.
You should have it in an area where friends come over and they go,
what's going on here? And it represents you. It represents your personality.
They can say, well, this is how you know, we love our life.
I know you got to a point where you were like really in demand.
I can remember I was talking to Eddie about it. And he was like, God,
Todd is so busy. Like he's like constantly working. Does it,
does it ever get to a point where it seemed like labor or like a T
does a dope Hendrick shirts on what you got there hidden by your gay
bandana. I'm sorry. It's more like a rancher's.
Band down. There you go. We're in Texas. Yeah.
Yeah. Those guys would have sequence in or something. I like that.
That's dope shirt.
You can help. It really I'll give it to you. That's the coolest.
One of the coolest shows I ever did. I have the greatest fans of any artist,
period living. They're just, they're awesome people.
And they show up in droves and we were doing a show one time and this,
this client in England came up and he goes, eh, and I said, dude,
that's the greatest jacket I've ever seen. And he goes, you like it? I go, yeah.
And he goes, it's yours. And I go, I'm not gonna take your jacket.
And in my mind, I go, I'm taking his jacket. He goes, he goes, no man.
Try it on. If it fits you, it's yours. And I thought, that's a fair, fair.
I try it on. I'm like, Oh buddy, perfect. He goes, I've got to fix it. He goes,
it's yours. Wow. Thank you. And the cool thing is about 10 years later,
I was in Toronto doing a show and an a kid came up, uh, artists,
kidney showed me his work briefly, which I find a bit hard to look at.
People's work in the middle of my show. And I'm like, Oh, that's awesome, dude.
And he goes, man, that's a great jacket. And I go, he was about my size. I go,
Hey, see if this fits you and it fit him. And I go, it's yours. Wow.
I can't believe it. And then other people were like, dude,
I just bought $60,000 painting. You gave him a jacket and he's like, Hey,
come on, man. You just gotta go with the flow.
Oh, you got to go with the flow.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free. Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch.
Between video.
An audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the Geri on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.